I believe you thank you son you want to
talk about it later over a game of catch
I'd like that what's going on family
with game night don't worry I brought
twister hey Rosa hey R snacks you know
in another lifetime you and I would have
made a hot ass couple
[Music]
agreed you guess you should be very
proud of yourself I know things aren't
exactly way you want to be right now but
uh I promise you they will approve thank
you Captain every time someone steps up
and says who they are the world becomes
a better more interesting place
so thank
you hey do you seriously only have two
wine glasses yeah I live alone well
you're going to need to get some more
cuz there's a lot of us here thank you
for doing this man of course we'll be
here every week Rosa I broke both your
wine glasses in your fridge door in your
bathroom every single
week Santiago I'm I'm on the phone
trible break I'm so sorry sir I can come
back later no it's too late the call is
ruined goodbye dear what do you want
well since there's a good chance that
things are coming to an end I just
wanted to say thank you for everything
that you've taught me I know you may not
see yourself as my mentor but of course
I do I've been mentoring you all this
time
what this is day
1,282 of a 9-year mentorship I had
mapped out for you under ordinary
circumstances I wouldn't reveal this to
you until day 3300 it was real there was
a binder not anymore no you can still
Mentor me if we don't work together we
could meet for breakfast every day you
could teach me over eggs eggs for
breakfast further behind than I thought
no look okay there are 10 hours left sir
if you talk fast enough you can teach me
everything interesting okay you have to
take notes do you think you can keep up
let's just say I was president of the
stenographers Club in high school for a
reason reason was the reason because you
were the only
member yes 5 minutes left what have I
missed professional handshake we did
that fingers with a/ cimet spread up
down then separate good acceptable
Fabrics cotton or cotton blend wool is
for outerwear only and silk is for sex
workers or musicians right good desserts
there are none if you were hungry you
should have had more dinner that's it
we're done you've been mentored oh my
God we did it I can't believe we did it
oh no we did it it's
over yes I agree up down
separation
separation I'm so glad you're helping me
maybe I won't blow it after all oh
you'll do plenty of blowing of that
flute now let's go a five 6 7
8 stop the nod meant start now not start
one second later again 5 6 7
stop are you playing the muffin man or
the garbage man huh do you know the
garbage man because I do because I'm
looking right at him again 5 6 7
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
okay why' you stop playing garbage man I
need some water what you need to do is
keep practicing garbage man I don't have
any more saliva and I don't have any
more time time for your excuses garbage
man now play again 5 six I don't want
your help anymore I'm not a garbage man
I'm a muffin man hi uh my name is Terry
Jeffs and I don't know how this is going
to go wait sir I'm captain Raymond Holt
of the 99th Precinct and I need to tell
you about this man now the audition
pieces about the play may not be
technically perfect in fact it may hurt
your ears you may consider it an insult
to music you may whisper to each other
Muffin Man more like garbage man come on
but you would be wrong this man has
taught me something he's taught me that
music is about heart and soul it's about
perseverance despite everything I put
him through he showed up here today and
you would be a fool not to put him in
your band thank you cine so again your
Alibi is a mysterious stranger handed
you the gun made you put your prints on
it robbed the store and then hid the gun
in your Underpants Well yeah if you say
it like that it don't sound believable
oh hey Captain did you get my report on
the Finley murder uh yeah I looked it
over nice work good thanks
Dad why is everyone staring at me you
just called Captain hold dad you said
thanks Dad what no I didn't I said
thanks man do you see me as a father
figure Peralta no if anything I see you
as a bother figure cuz you're always
bothering me hey show your father some
respect I didn't call him Dad no no no
no Jacob I take it as a compliment it's
not a big deal I called Vivian mom once
and she's my fiance guys jump on that Bo
has psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Holt Daddy hey Daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dad
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lies since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the hold up but
the dad thing that happened he admitted
that his Alibi was a lie it was a trap
all part of my crazy devious plan I
believe you thank you
son you want to talk about it later over
a game of catch I'd like that you took a
vacation 14 days ago and yet you already
want another day off odd unless you need
it for a unique once in a lifetime
occurrence perhaps a proposal to your
girlfriend Joseline what you've been
dating for a year you met each other's
parents and you just got your nails done
to present her with a
ring Jin broke up with me what I want
the day off so I can sit alone listen to
death metal and get my head right but
what about my nail polish solve get in
my nails done make me feel better for a
second this is a trick to throw me off I
bet things are better than ever and you
oh you really are crying Rosa stop I
give up I want you to know I'm sorry for
cying win this thing and enjoy your day
off and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal just know
I'm always here okay I'd like
that no what are you freak's doing we're
leaving the competition some things are
more important than a game no they're
not you like it not at all you can leave
not a
chance is a seat
taken you really got to do this D my
name is Rachel Weinstein I'm a graduate
student on setic called to study birds
at the University of Buenos ciris you
know Cornell has a far better
Ornithology department and it's right
here in New York Cornell has accused me
of robbing a bank and is going to send
me to jail for 15 years I guess we're
dropping the metaphor I don't know why
you're here you're not going to change
my mind I
know I just wanted to say goodbye okay
goodbye I hope you know your family's
going to miss you I don't care I barely
speak to them I was talking about the
99 be safe Rachel
[Music]
wiste
oh fresh
air wow I don't say that a lot there's
one thing I still don't understand did
you know you had the wrong murder weapon
oh excellent question sir yes I spotted
the missing Dental award when I first
took the case I asked around weeks ago
turns out a cleaning lady knocked it
over and shattered it then why did you
run in there like that because in
talking to you I realized what Philip's
worst fear actually was that we would
think he was just some dummy that got
lucky right he had planned the perfect
crime and it killed him when you said he
was sloppy and impulsive he needed us to
know how smart he was hi like someone
else I know yep
Kevin I'm proud of you
per thank you
sir now let's go get some sleep hey
guys my goodness we're almost late for
work oh well in that case good morning
sir good morning
BR God I love this
[Music]
job
so you're
leaving that must have been a hard
decision
honestly it wasn't it's funny on my
first day here I asked Jeffers to tell
me about everyone told me you were a
great detective but the one thing you
couldn't figure out was how to grow
up
well I think you finally figured it
out well thank you sir I couldn't have
done it without you over the years
you've sometimes referred to me as uh
something of a father figure did I I
didn't realize that but I want you to
know if I had had a son and uh he had
turned out like
you I would be very proud of him
thanks
Sir
W wasn't expecting to get this emotional
it's not bad for an old robot
huh
s sir did you just make a joke I believe
I did yes I guess in the end we rubbed
off on each other quite a
bit tile of your sex
movie did I do that right it was
perfect